i'm going to talk about a technology
that we're developing at oxford now that
we think is going to change the way
that computer games and hollywood movies
are being made
that technology is simulating humans
it's simulated humans with a simulated
body
and a simulated nervous system to
control that body
um now before i talk more about that um
technology let's have a quick look at
what
human characters look like at the moment
in computer games
now this is a clip from a game called
grand theft auto 3 we already saw that
briefly yesterday and what you can see
is
it is actually a very good game it's one
of the most successful games of all
times but what you'll see is that all
the animations in this game
are very repetitive
they pretty much look the same i've made
them run into a wall here over and over
again
and you can see it looks always the same
the reason for that is
that these characters are actually not
real characters they are a
graphical visualization of a character
to produce these animations an animator
at
a studio has to anticipate um what's
going to happen
in the actual game and then has to
animate um that particular sequence so
he or she sits down
animates it and tries to display what's
gonna happen and then these particular
animations are just played back at
appropriate times um in the computer
game now the result of that is that
you can't have real interactivity
all you have is animations that are
played back at more or less the
appropriate times it also means that
games
aren't really going to be as surprising
as they could be because you only get
out of it at least in terms of the
character what you actually put into it
there's no real emergence there and
thirdly as i said most of the animations
look very repetitive because of that
now
the only way to get around that is to
actually simulate the human body and to
simulate um that bit of the nervous
system of the brain that controls that
body and maybe if i could have you for a
quick demonstration to show what the
difference is
because i mean
very very um it's very trivial if i push
chris a bit like this for example he'll
react to it if i push him from a
different angle he'll react to it
differently and that's because he has a
physical body and because he has the
motor skills to control that body it's a
very trivial thing it's not something
you get in computer games at the moment
at all thank you very much that's it
yeah so that's exactly
that's what we're trying to simulate uh
not chris specifically i should say but
um human in general
now
we started working on this a while ago
at oxford university and we tried to
start very simply what we tried to do
was teach a stick figure on how to walk
that stick figure is physically
stimulated you can see it here on the
screen so it's subject to gravity has
joints etc so if you just run the
simulation it'll just collapse like this
um the tricky bit is now to put a
controller ai control in it that
actually makes it work and for that we
use the neural network which we based on
that part of the nervous system that we
have in our spine that controls walking
in humans it's called the central
pattern generator so we simulated that
as well and then the really tricky bit
is to teach that network how to walk
for that we used artificial evolution
genetic algorithms we heard about those
already yesterday and i suppose that
most of you are familiar with that
already but just briefly the concept is
is that you create um a large number of
different individuals neural networks in
this case all of which are random at the
beginning you hook these up in this case
to the virtual muscles of that um
two-legged creature here and
hope that it does something interesting
at the beginning they're all going to be
very boring most of them won't move at
all but some of them might make a tiny
step those are then selected by the
algorithm
reproduced with mutation and
recombination to introduce sex as well
and you repeat that process over and
over again until you have something that
walks in this case in a straight line
like this so what that was the idea
behind this when we started this i set
up a simulation
one evening it took about three to four
hours to run the simulation got up the
next morning went to the computer um and
looked at the result and was hoping for
something that walked in a straight line
like i just demonstrated and this is
what i got instead
so um it was a back to the drawing board
for us
um we did get it to work uh eventually
um after tweaking uh bits here and there
and this is an example of a successful
evolutionary run so that what you'll see
in a moment is um a very simple biped
that's learning how to walk using
artificial evolution at the beginning it
can't work at all
but it'll get better and better over
time
so this is the one that can't walk at
all
now after five generations of applying
an evolutionary process a genetic
algorithm
is getting a tiny bit better
generation 10 and it will take a few
steps more
still not quite there
but now after generation 20 it actually
walks in a straight line without falling
over
that was a real breakthrough for us
it was academically quite a challenging
project and once we had reached that
stage we were quite confident that we
could
try and do other things as well um with
with this approach actually simulating
the body and simulating that part of the
nervous system that controls it
now at this stage it also became clear
that this could be very exciting for
things like computer games or online
worlds so what you see here is the
character standing there and there's an
obstacle in his way that we put in its
way
and what you see is it's going to fall
over the obstacle
now the interesting bit is if i move the
obstacle a tiny bit to the right which
is what i'm doing now here
it'll fall over it
in a completely different way
and again if you move the obstacle a
tiny bit
it'll again fall differently
now what you see by the way in the at
the top there's are some of the neural
activations being fed into the virtual
muscles
okay that's the video thanks now this
might look kind of trivial but it's
actually very important because this is
not something you get at the moment in
any interactive or any virtual worlds
now at this stage we decided to start a
company and move this further because
obviously this was just a very simple
blocky biped what we really wanted was a
full human body so when we started the
company we hired a team of physicists
software engineers and biologists to
work on this and the first thing we had
to work on was to create
the human body basically it's got to be
relatively fast so you can run it on a
normal machine but it's got to be
accurate enough it looks good enough
basically so um we put a quite a bit of
biomechanical knowledge into this thing
um
and made it try to make it as realistic
as possible what you see here on the
screen right now is a very simple
visualization of that body um should add
that it's very simple to add things like
hair clothes etc
but what we've done here is use a very
simple simple visualization so you can
concentrate on the movement now what i'm
going to do right now in a moment is
just push this character a tiny bit and
we'll see what happens
nothing really interesting basically it
folds over but it falls over like a rag
doll basically the reason for that is is
that there's no intelligence in it
it becomes interesting when you put
artificial intelligence into it so this
character now has um motor skills in the
upper body
nothing in the legs yet in this
particular one but what it will do i'm
going to push it again it will realize
autonomously that it's being pushed it's
going to stick out its hands and it's
going to turn around into the fold and
try and catch the fall
so that's what you're seeing here
now
it gets really interesting if you then
add the ai for the lower part of the
body as well so here we've got the same
character i'm going to push it a bit
harder um now higher than i just push
push chris but what you'll see is
so again it's going to receive a push
now from from the left
what you'll see is it takes steps
backwards it tries to counterbalance it
tries to look at the place where it
thinks it's going to land
i'll show you this again
and then finally hits the floor
now
this becomes really exciting um when you
push that character in different
directions again just as i've done um
that's where that's something that you
cannot do right now at the moment you
only have empty computer graphics in in
in games what this is now is a real
simulation that's what i want to show
you now so here's the same character
with the same behavior i've just shown
you but now i'm just going to push it
from different directions first starting
with the push from the right
this is all slow motion by the way so we
can see what's going on
now the angle will have changed a tiny
bit so
you can see that the reaction is
different
again i push now this time from the
front
and you see it falls differently and now
from the left
and it folds differently
that was really exciting for us to see
that that was the first time we've seen
that this is by the way the first time
the public thesis as well because we
have been in stealth mode i haven't
shown this to anybody yet
um
now just a fun thing what happens if you
put that character this is now a wooden
version of it but it's got the same eye
in it what if you put that character on
a slippery surface like ice we just did
that for love just to see what happens
and this is what happens
it's nothing we had to do about this we
just took this character that i just
talked about put it on the slippery
surface and this is what you get out of
it and that's a really fascinating thing
about this approach
um now when we went to um film studios
and games developers and and showed them
that technology
got a very good response and what they
said was the first thing they need
immediately as virtual stuntmen um
because stuns are obviously very
dangerous they're very expensive and
there are a lot of stunt scenes that you
cannot do obviously because you can't
really allow the um someone to be
seriously hurt so they wanted to have a
digital version of stuntman and that's
what we've been working on for the past
few months and that's our first um
product that we're going to release and
in a couple of weeks
so here are just a few very simple
scenes of the guy just being kicked
that's what people want that's what
we're giving them
you can see it's always reacting this is
not a dead body this is a body
who basically in this particular case
feels the force and tries to protect its
head and the other thing is quite a big
blow again
you feel kind of sorry for that thing
and we've seen it so many times now we
don't really care anymore but
there are much worse videos than this by
the way which i have taken out but uh
um
now here's another one um what people
wanted um as a behavior was to have a an
explosion a strong force applied to the
character and have the character react
to it in midair so that you don't have a
character that looks lim but actually a
character you can use an action film
straight away that looks kind of alive
in mid-air as well so this character is
going to be hit by force it's going to
realize it's in the air and it's going
to try and um
well stick out its arm in the direction
where it's landing
that's one angle here's another angle
we now think that the realism we're
achieving with this is good enough to be
used in films and let's just have a look
at a slightly different visualization
this is something i just got last night
from an animation studio in london who
are using our software and
experimenting with it right now
so this is exactly the same behavior
that you saw but in slightly
better rendered versions
so if you look at the character
carefully you see there are lots of body
movements going on none of which you
have to animate like in the old days no
matter how to actually animate them this
is all happening automatically in the
simulation this is a slightly different
angle
and again a slow motion version of this
this is incredibly quick this is
happening in real time you can run the
simulation in real time in front of your
eyes change it if you want to and you
get the animation straight out of it at
the moment doing something like this by
hand would take you probably a couple of
days
this is another behavior they requested
i'm not quite sure why but we've done it
anyway it's a very simple behavior that
shows you the power of this approach in
this case the character's hands are
fixed to a particular point in space and
all we've told the characters to
struggle
and you it looks organic it looks
realistic you feel kind of sorry for the
guy it's even worse and this is another
video i just got last night if you
render that a bit more realistically
now i'm showing this to you just to show
you the how organic it actually can feel
how realistic it can look and this is
all a physical simulation of the body
using ai to drive virtual muscle muscles
in that body
now
one thing we just did for love was to
create a slightly more complex dance
scene and one of the most famous stunts
is the one where james bond
jumps off a dam in switzerland and then
is caught by a caught by a bungee
got a very short clip here
yeah you can just about see it here um
in this case that we were using a real
stamina it was a very dangerous stunt it
was just voted i think in the standard
times is one of the most impressive
stunts now we've just tried and looked
at our character and asked ourselves can
we do that ourselves as well can we use
the physical simulation of the character
use artificial intelligence put that
artificial intelligence into the
character drive virtual muscles simulate
the way he jumps off the dam and then
skydive afterwards and have him caught
by a bungee
afterwards we did that it took about all
together just two hours pretty much to
create the simulation and that's what it
looks like here
now this could do with a bit more work
it's still very early stages and we
pretty much just did this for a lot just
to see what we get out of it
that what we found over the past few
months is that this this approach that
we pretty much stumbled upon is is
incredibly powerful
we are ourselves surprised what you
actually get out of um out of the
simulations there's very often very
surprising behavior that you didn't
predict before
and there's so many things we can do
with this right now um the first thing
as i said is going to be virtual
stuntman um several students are using
the software now to produce virtual
statement and they're going to hit the
screen um quite soon actually for some
major productions
the second thing is
video games with this technology video
games will look different and they will
feel very different for the first time
you'll have actors that really feel very
interactive that have a real value that
really react
i think that's going to be incredibly
exciting i'm probably starting with
sports games which are going to become
much more interactive um but i
particularly i'm really excited about
using this technology in in online
worlds like there for example that
tomato has shown us the degree of
interactivity you're going to get is
totally different i think from what
you're getting right now
um a third thing we are looking at and
very interesting is simulation
we've been approached by several
simulation companies but one project
we're particularly excited about which
we're starting next month is to use our
technology and particularly the walking
technology
to help aid surgeons who work on
children with them cerebral palsy
to predict the outcome of operations on
these children as you probably know the
it's very difficult to predict what the
outcome of a of an operation is if you
try and correct the gate um the classic
quote is it's i think it's unpredictable
at best is what people think right now
is the outcome now what we want to do
with our software is allow
our surgeons to have a tool um we're
going to simulate the gait of a
particular child and the surgeon can
then work on that simulation and try out
different ways to improve that gait
before he actually commits to to an
actual surgery that's one project we're
particularly excited about
and that's going to start next month
um
just finally um this is only just the
beginning we can only do several
behaviors right now the ai isn't good
enough to simulate a full human body um
well the body yes but not all the motor
skills that we have and i think we're
only there if we can have something like
ballet dancing right now we don't have
that but i'm very sure that we were able
to do that at some stage um we do have
one unintentional dancer actually which
i just the last thing i wanted to show
you this was an ai controller that was
produced and evolved half evolved i
should say to produce balance basically
so you kick the guy and the guy is
supposed to counterbalance that's what
we thought was going to come out of this
but this is what emerged out of it in
the end
so this was not something we actually
put in there he just started to
create that dance himself
it's actually better down to than i am
what you see after a while i think he
even goes into a climax right at the end
so that all happened automatically we
didn't put it in there that's just the
simulation creating this itself
basically so it's uh
thanks
i've
not quite joined travolta yet but um
we're working on that as well so uh
thanks very much for your
that time really incredible thanks